I have a tendency to overshare
when I first meet people.
So in keeping with that habit,
I wanted to share
that I'm a medical oddity.
I'm a doctor who specializes
in saving forests.
My journey has been unusual.
And through it, I've learned how vital
tropical forests are for our health.
As soon as I finished my internal
medicine training,
I traded in my scrubs for a hazmat suit.
I joined the Epidemic Intelligence Service
at the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention,
and for nine years,
I was a disease detective.
I chased outbreaks around the world.
I trekked through the jungle to research
a bat hunting festival.
I even vaccinated raccoons
from an airplane.
On most days, it was my dream job.
But there were others
when what I saw was a nightmare.
Like when I went to West
and Central Africa
to help fight the two biggest
Ebola epidemics ever.
I came back from both of those deployments
with the same feeling.
That our reactive approach
to public health is inherently flawed.
We focus on preparing for outbreaks
so that we can respond quickly,
but it's rarely that easy.
Maybe a virus, like the one
that causes COVID,
spreads between people
before they know they're sick.
Maybe people choose to not take
a safe and effective vaccine.
And before we know it,
the outbreak grows
into an epidemic or even pandemic.
In other words, we act
as if outbreaks are inevitable.
If you ask me, this is medical negligence.
Preparing and responding
are critical, no doubt,
but alone, they're not enough.
This begs the question:
What if we could also prevent outbreaks
before they even begin?
Well, there's good news.
We can.
And how we do so may surprise you.
Some researchers believe
the West African Ebola epidemic
began with an axe.
Communities in rural Guinea,
for their survival,
had no choice but to clear
forests for farms.
Then, in 2013,
an 18-month-old boy died of Ebola.
He is believed to have caught
the virus from bats
that lived in a hollow tree
where he played.
Put another way,
the virus likely spilled over
from bats into this boy,
making him patient zero.
From there, Ebola spread,
killing more than 11,000
people in West Africa.
Ebola's animal origins,
however, aren't unique.
All five viral pandemics
from 1918 through 2009
can be traced to animals,
and the same is likely true for COVID.
Perhaps most concerningly,
the estimated number of undiscovered
viruses circulating in animals
that could potentially spill over
is over 600,000.
Spillover is also becoming more common
because of what we humans are doing:
wildlife trade,
industrial-scale animal farms
and, my focus today,
clearing of tropical forests.
Changes in the way land is used,
particularly deforestation,
may be the single biggest driver
of new animal-borne diseases.
There are three key ways
that deforestation leads to disease.
First, the animals
that survived deforestation,
such as some types of bats,
tend to be ones that can
live alongside people.
For whatever the reason,
these animals often carry germs
that can infect us.
Second, when people move
into deforested areas,
they come into closer
contact with wildlife,
creating opportunities
to pass germs back and forth.
Finally, animals are more likely
to spread disease
when they're stressed
from losing their homes.
To make matters worse,
the threat of infectious disease
is only growing as our planet warms.
Over half of known
infectious diseases in humans
have been aggravated
by climate change at some point.
The World Health Organization
even considers climate change
the greatest threat
to human health we face today.
Now, I know what some of you are thinking.
Would anybody really miss these guys?
If we killed the bats,
wouldn't that solve our problem?
Of course not.
And I'm not just saying that
because bats are my second favorite
group of animals after snakes.
(Laughter)
If anything, we'd just get exposed
to more viruses when killing them.
We also depend upon bats
for pollination and insect control.
But there is something we can do right now
that would have an immediate impact
on health and climate.
What's more, it'll cost way less
than fighting the next pandemic.
So what is this solution?
Protecting tropical forests.
People don't clear-cut forests
because it's fun work.
Corporations may do it
to make money in global markets.
Rainforest communities,
many of which are very poor,
may do it too, just to survive.
Understanding these dynamics
gives us a road map to reverse it.
In the early 2000s, for example,
Brazilian government officials monitored
forest loss with satellites
and cracked down on illegal deforestation.
They returned territory
to Indigenous peoples
who have successfully managed
the Amazon for thousands of years.
Under public pressure,
businesses stopped selling beef and soy
from recently deforested lands.
These efforts paid off.
From 2004 to 2012,
deforestation in the Amazon
plummeted by over 80 percent.
Even better, agricultural
output increased,
dispelling the myth that there's
a trade-off between forests and food.
But here's the tricky thing
about deforestation.
It's hyper local.
There's no one-size-fits-all solution.
That means, above all else,
we need to listen.
That may sound a little fluffy,
but bear with me.
In Indonesian Borneo,
a nonprofit called Health and Harmony
conducted what it calls radical listening
to arrive at community-designed
solutions to deforestation.
Communities concluded
that deforestation could be reversed
if they had quality
health care and better jobs.
So the nonprofit, along
with local partners, built a clinic.
They trained community members
to farm organically.
They invested in youth education.
Lo and behold, the communities were right.
Over the next decade,
deforestation dropped.
Meanwhile, health improved.
Infant mortality decreased by two thirds.
What we see here is that people and planet
don't need to be in conflict.
We have solutions
to address deforestation.
And if we implement them wisely,
we can prevent outbreaks
and slow climate change.
Preventing outbreaks by saving nature
will also help ensure
that income doesn't dictate outcome.
The tools we use
to respond to outbreaks --
medicines, vaccines,
even information --
are inequitably distributed.
In contrast, prevention
benefits everyone equally.
So how can we accelerate uptake
of preventative solutions to outbreaks?
By building bridges between the health,
climate and conservation sectors.
Pandemics, climate change
and environmental destruction
feed off each other.
But like the health sector,
the climate sector hasn't fully
recognized the value of nature.
Nature-focused projects, for example,
can get us over 30 percent
of the emissions reductions
needed to reach our climate goals,
but only receive about five percent
of climate funding.
In my own work,
I was also conditioned to overlook nature.
For years, I was made to feel guilty
for caring about species
other than humans.
Like it was a betrayal of the oath
I took when I became a doctor.
Right after I finished my training,
I met a world-renowned
physician and scientist
who I looked up to for years.
I was excited to ask him for his thoughts
on how to improve human well-being
while safeguarding the planet.
He looked at me and slowly said,
"I don't care about polar bears."
At first I was shocked.
And then I felt embarrassed.
But from what I've seen from fighting
outbreaks for over a decade,
I'm finally comfortable admitting
that I do care about polar bears.
And bats.
(Applause)
And bats
and forests
and people.
We all need to.
Because there is no human health
or animal health or environmental health.
They're one and the same.
In West Africa,
it may have taken just one infected animal
to spark an Ebola epidemic
that killed more than 11,000 people.
But it will take everyone to sustain
the delicate ecological balance
that we all depend upon.
Thank you.
(Applause)